based on the
2016 constitutional revision, the reform of
the political governance system in
algeria remains at the heart of our
partnership and benefits from the support of
the european union for its
implementation, particularly in the areas
of justice and  participatory democracy
we are convinced that
yesterday civil society plays an important role in this
process of appropriating reforms
and defending democratic progress
I welcome the signing
today of the
financing agreement for a support program
to the agricultural sector,
this will contribute to improving
water management,
support for agro-industry and the fight against
agricultural pollution,
therefore, our cooperation between partnerships
is extremely concrete.
I also wish to reaffirm our
will as well  that trade regulation measures
are taken in compliance with
the association agreement we have
agreed today  finalized our
discussions these remarks as
soon as possible and if possible before the
end of the year in a spirit of
mutual cooperation security challenges
know no
borders we are determined to
face them in a spirit of cooperation
between us for the benefit of  our
citizens we have experiences to
share shared information and a
lot of work to do in 100 years
or apartment same space we share it
the same year on both sides
are convinced that this head mother is
not right fractures  but
on the contrary they have relations and
strengthening of the cooperation of us
our two spaces we have interest of
course return of stability and peace
in our region we both will
cooperate and continue to cooperate in the
fight against terrorism
when  the farms and the radicalization
in fact this dynamic which has never
ceased
it will I am certain because the
will exists  e on both sides it
will accelerate to ensure that
this dialogue that seven
strategic partners that we all want is
well understood on both sides and is for the
benefit of both parties